[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to Harry
Potter theory today we have a very
special box that has been sent to me by
I believe Harry Potter themselves Warner
Bros so I'm very excited to see what's
in here I have no idea
so I let's just get to it interesting
it's a box within a box this is cool
[Music]
calling all wizards welcome to Harry
Potter wizards unite to celebrate the
launch of the game we wanted to ensure
you have everything you need to embark
on your Wizarding World adventure and
help the Statue of secrecy task force
contain the calamity you will need all
the help you can get to overcome the
magic that has brought these artifacts
creatures people and more into the
muggle world thank you for being part of
this magical journey with us
sincerely Warner Bros games and the
antique so let's see what's inside shall
we so first we've got a pop socket for
on the back of any phone
[Music]
so them thank you guys this is really
really sweet so you just stick this on
the back and then I've got a nice
wireless charger to charge any of my
devices right handhelds I guess you
could say
[Music]
[Applause]
let's be buds
[Music]
well guys I hope you enjoyed this little
unboxing video thank you so much Warner
Bros games and neon tech this was very
very unexpected as I said before a
surprise to be sure but a welcome one
thank you so much guys I hope you
enjoyed the other video that I made
about Harry Potter wizards unite so go
out and play some games
[Music]